Hi! Happy Pizzamas!
It has been a tough few weeks.
I mean, it’s been a tough year.
Even for my cat, and she doesn’t really
understand celebrity deaths or politics.
She is more of a philosophy and golf kind
of gal.
My name is Lex.
I have a YouTube channel, but more importantly,
I have this cat.
Her name is Felicity, she’s been an indoor
cat all her life, she is nine years old, and
I adopted her about a month ago.
She’s very friendly, she likes being stroked
and sitting on laps, and the other night at
about 3am, she decided to scoot her butt across
my bed sheet, I guess it was itchy, and then
I forgot, and I slept on it.
The sheet.
Not her butthole.
But at this point, in terms of hygiene, there’s
basically no difference.
There are a lot of great things about owning
a cat.
Great for me. Selfish.
She gives me a sense of routine and purpose.
She makes me responsible for someone other
than myself, which in turn makes me more responsible
for myself, because I have to remember to
do things like clean up my living space and
not leave old food just on the ground.
She really relaxes me.
A cat is basically like a furry hot water
bottle with a face.
If you picture that literally, it’s not
very relaxing.
I mean, also, she’s just so cute, oh my
God, it’s physically painful, please make
her leave the room.
My cat gets stuff out of this, too.
Food, shelter, water: the power trio.
Catnip, so, regular access to legal highs,
and an owner, who, like the parent of a newborn
(how’s it going, Hank?) has committed to
the fact that they will not get a good night’s
sleep for a very long time.
So I don’t mind that she likes to be the
little spoon, or that she wakes me up in the
middle of the night.
Although she has developed this great trick
where she reaches out at about 2am and punches
me in the face to try and get me to wake up
and stroke her.
It’s so adorable.
The more I think about it, though, the more
it’s weird that I’ve brought this animal
into my home.
She’s domesticated, obviously, but I don’t
think that my bedroom is necessarily her natural
habitat.
I really don’t want to delve into the horrifying
depths of the indoor vs. outdoor cat conversation.
People yell there.
As Felic has never been outside, she’s a
bit more senior, she would be in a lot of
trouble if I just opened the front door and
said, “Go!
Run! Be free, my child!
Good luck with the big metal dogs with wheels.”
If they’ve never known anything different,
do you think they’re just like, “Cool,
this is the world.
I’m gonna eat some treats given to me by
the big stupid talking noodle.”
Or does my cat look at the very large tall climbing
tree that I bought her and think, like,
"What—what are you trying to pull here? That is not a tree."
Something I do find interesting is the difference
in lifespan.
I looked up the lifespan of a rabbit, and
it said eight to twelve years domesticated,
one to two years in the wild.
In the wild, animals are fighting for food,
mates, survival, sometimes it’s cold, they
can have untreated illnesses and injuries,
predators are always giving them heck, nobody
lets them eat a small bit of cheese if they’ve
been good that day.
Is it better to have a long, comfortable life
that’s not necessarily instinctive to you,
or to have a short, natural one where you
run free, terrified, with no idea what cheese even is?
I am, of course, just talking about domesticated
animals, obviously, not like orcas in a tank.
I guess you could say that humans weren’t
really supposed to live inside, though.
But someone what like, “Hey, I put a rug
down in this cave.
You should come in here ‘cause it’s, um,
it’s better."
Someone fact-check that for me.
A big problem that’s come from our love
of pets is overbreeding.
We are creating a huge overpopulation problem
that often leads to animals being without homes.
That’s why animal charities always encourage
you to spay and neuter your pets, and to adopt
rather than shop if you’re thinking of getting
an animal.
People think rescue animals are so damaged
and difficult, but Felic is not damaged or difficult.
Although I have taught her to high five, but
she refuses to distinguish between the high
five and the low five.
That’s the same thing, Felic. It's the same.
I think my cat is very happy here with me,
and I can’t go back in time and undo the
domestication of pets, so I am happy to give
one a loving home.
Who was the first person to look at animals,
especially like wild cats and wolves, and go,
“Yeah, I want that guy licking yogurt
off my hand.”
I don’t have the answers to any of these
questions.
Maybe you do.
Thank you for joining me here on vlogbrothers
during Pizzamas, and for sticking with me
when I decided I just wanted to make a video
about cats.
I’ve been on the World Wide Web for a while,
I know what you kids like.
John, I’ll see you on Tuesday.
I’ve always wanted to say that.